voilà la première ministre les français
sont totalement asphyxiée vous le savez
par la flambée des prix à la pompe la
position des députés les républicains
est très clair nous demandons une baisse
durable des taxes sur les carburants
pour tous je dis bien une baisse durable
et pour tous plutôt que des mesures
temporaires qui ne profiterait qu'à une
partie des français en oubliant
totalement les classes moyennes cette
baisse des taxes est impérative pour
rendre de pouvoir d'achat aux français
alors que l'état a encaissé plus de 20
milliards de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires depuis le début de
l'année vous le savez les textes
représente 60% du coût d'un plein
c'est une mesure de justice sociale d'en
finir avec ce niveau de taxation
inacceptable c'est taxe pénalise en
premier lieu ceux qui travaillent et
ceux qui sont tributaires leur voiture
madame la première ministre dans votre
discours de politique générale vous
annonciez vouloir avec respect et
changer d'attitude en écoutant les
oppositions
prouvez nous que ce n'étaient pas que
des mots prouvez nous que la présidence
jupitérienne d' emmanuel macron s'est
bien terminée bloquer les prix à la
pompe à 1 euro 50 est une obligation
vous ne pouvez pas refuser aux français
ses propositions des députés les
républicains merci à vous